I'm sorry for the ladies and gentlemen
we're just waiting for Liz to come back
from committee services to confirm a few
things to us more this is here
well good evening everybody and welcome
to the planning hearing this evening
just a few house rules if you have a
mobile phone can you switch it off with
silent please and I know it must be
quite tempting to shout out at please
don't repeat us interrupt the flow of
conversation so there you are
and erm before we can start tonight to
the panel to introduce themselves on the
top table here make sure - legal
services my name is David Jeffrey I'm
the Planning Manager for tonight's
meeting my role is to provide impartial
advice to clarify any planning issues
that arise and to assist members
decision taking in doing so I'm bound by
the Royal Town Planning Institute's code
of Professional Conduct planning
committee members are not bound by my
advice for advice for officers or their
recommendations Baron rather stone
planning officer Joseph planning officer
thank you very much indeed thank you I
like - oh you are the only apologies for
absence councillor crumpet uncounseled
Jennings's substitute counsel to JUnit
with councillor Adams substituting and
councillor Henshaw Seraphin thank you
very much
are there any discs
well then disclosures of interest Kelso
Adam Thank You chair item number five
one nine zero two zero six four slash
ful I'm one nine zero two zero five four
slash LBC on the ward member and I'll be
speaking as part of the application very
much counselor kettle just not for
clarification mr. chairman listen case
everybody is concerned I use my laptop
for accessing planning applications
which were discussing to make sure I
have all the details on the screen
rather than on paper form which is why I
should be using my laptop I'm not
sending any personal emails or having
any contact outside thank you very much
indeed
thank you and other disclosures my
silent minutes after the meeting
religious minister take everybody's read
the minutes from the last meeting
are they happy to confirm yes you're
happy
yeah P good good thank you very much
indeed
right thank you right which I think we
would bring forward the application is
number six on the agenda page 19 of the
zero-to-four
double to a pretty ful and I would ask
the committee we can bring this forward
to their two officers delegation because
I understand there are no speakers on
here this tonight we haven't got a ward
member or parish council in a mistake
so are we happy to bring this to a
caucus relegation yes thank you very
much can we have a propose on that
proposed by a council field and second
if I save it second by councillor
Fleming thank you all in favor of
delegating yes Kelsey kettle you're
listening okay all in favor of
delegating this yes can we shake hands
please on this thank you very much thank
you yes yes I think that the agent has
chose not to speak with resolve we have
resolved this to delegate it to the
officers in intercourse with
recommendation yes
yeah thanks
I was just gonna suggest to mr. chairman
that mr. Nash relation that the
Constitution has changed to allow that a
nap take place
I believe mr. Romney actually knows that
counsel counsel about apologies I was
advised by the planner manager that you
wouldn't speak if it was delegated to
officers okay thanks for coming thank
you
right right panel we will now go on to
add to the first item the agenda which
is application 1902 three six zero six a
big lut Muse laid poor head lame term
within Arden and the percentage opposite
is Aaron thank you thank you to the
application site lie to the east pool
head lane as identified by the black dot
on this plan so just here site lies
within the West Midlands Greenbelt
pardon special landscape area with
building within the truck built a pareo
boundary of would end which is
identified as a category for local
service village within the councils
adopted core strategy this slide
identifies the application sight out if
outlined in red the site comprises of an
existing dwelling and associated garden
with bicular access from pool head lane
so this is a site here existing dwelling
and the access is approximately here
outline planning permission is sought
for the demolition of the existing
dwelling the erection of a new building
containing five new apartments and
associated works all matters are
reserved except for access and layout
they bring dwellings lie to the north
and south of the site here and here the
site also shares a boundary with land
associated with the dwellings known as
grey zone and a mica which front broad
lane to the south so here and here you
can see the shared boundary along here
and here
opposite the site lies loud Britton Park
Golf Club which you can see just here
old Timbers which is a great two listed
building is shown in red to the south of
the plan approximately here this fighter
is an aerial image of the area the
approximate location of the site is
outlined in red here the building here
opposite the site you can see the golf
club and the neighboring properties to
the north to the south and broad lane
traveling along to the east
this slide shows existing site plan on
the left-hand side and the proposed site
plan on the right existing site has
mature conifer trees to the west and
boundary where it Front's Paul head lane
just here at the bottom of the slide the
existing driveway shown just here
sweeping around to the front of the
building and the outline of the existing
dwelling is shown approximately here
with Gardens over here to the east to
the right of the slide is a proposed
site plan all matters are reserved
except for access and lay out the
existing access is proposed to be
retained from Paul head lane over here
but extended up to the north
with temperance beta proposed openness
area here and five visitor parking
spaces proposed here to the front of the
building this slide shows illustrative
floor plans for the proposed development
outline planning permission is sought
for five apartments on the site this
slide shows what they could look like at
the moment the slide show three levels
of accommodation with two apartments at
ground floor two at first floor and one
on the second floor and currently they
comprised of three number of three
numbers of two-bedroom apartments and
two numbers of three bedrooms apartments
this application is a resubmission of an
earlier application application 1901
zero-five-zero full a UT which was
withdrawn the key changes are shown on
this slide you can see the previous
scheme here in the hatched the
illustrative drawing shown here in the
bold and the red line shows the existing
dwelling on the site the access is
proposed over on this side you see the
neighboring properties Garrett and their
side elevation the other neighbor is
shown to the right of the image this
photograph was taken looking east when
Paul head lane you see the band of
conifer trees at the front of the site
and the existing access going in this
photograph was taken from within the
site you can see the front elevation of
the existing dwelling and the existing
driveway this photograph was taken from
the rear looking at the rear elevation
of the existing dwelling on the site can
see it is here and the trees you can see
in the background of this image
this photograph was taken near to the
neighboring property because you the
neighboring Garret here close border
fencing the edge of the property within
the application site this is a proposed
location of the new access planning
round you can see the neighboring
property with their garage habitable
windows and a closed boarded fence this
photograph has taken from the we're
looking down towards a rear garden of
the property you're a number of updates
which have been circulating on the
update sheet there's also verbal update
for this application which seeks to make
minor moments the officer report on page
14 of the officer report the first
sentence of the second to last paragraph
has been updated to make reference to
paragraph 133 of the MPPs
in addition the first sentence of the
final paragraph of the opted for on page
14 has also been updated to make
reference to paragraphs one three four
one four three and one for for the MPP F
respectively final sentence in the last
paragraph on page 14 of the officer
reports been updated to make reference
to a hundred and forty five of the MPP F
and there is also one final update to
the first sentence of the second
paragraph on page 15 of the officer
report to make reference to 146
of the NPP F proposal is considered to
represent inappropriate development
within the Greenbelt for it so no very
special circumstances which clearly
outweigh the harm identified to the
openness of the Greenbelt development is
also considers have an adverse impact on
humanity of the neighboring properties
and a character of the area including
the items special landscape area it is
therefore recommended that planning
permission is refused for the reason set
out in the officer report thank you
Thank You Erin we've come to our first
speaker
councillor John Brougham from tamatha
nard and parish council
goody-goody you news to brother Han you
you just press the button in the middle
jolly good
and you have three minutes thank you the
council has I believe about viewers the
desirability of flats and has a positive
view of the need for smaller dwellings
and has established within the pending
NDP the desirability of such properties
the only existing flats are within the
conversion of a very large Victorian
mansion set in 58 or so setback circle
of meters from the road and residing
about two miles outside would end local
service village
but if flats are to replace houses they
need to be built in an appropriate
manner you know in an appropriate
environment and leafy country lanes such
as pool head Lane populated by spacious
single depth dwellings is inappropriate
and contrary to CS 15 core strategy
which states new housing within LS fees
will take place through small scale
schemes on suitable sites within its
boundaries whilst the proposed scheme is
within a ribbon development by virtue of
its much greater scale it is not limited
in scope as it increases habitation from
one dwelling to five dwellings its
footprint is larger but more
significantly its volume is very much
larger and is taller due to the
extension to three floors
additionally the provision of hard
services surface access to the rear of
the garden and hard standing to ten
vehicles requiring the removal of a
number of mature trees is contrary to
established practice and potentially
creates the unwelcome precedent of high
volumes of vehicles
stored or otherwise housed in rear
gardens furthermore due to its size and
use of its rear garden for access by a
large number of vehicles the impact upon
its to neighbors in pool head Lane and
its two rear access neighbors in broad
Lane is unacceptable and adversely
affects the openness of the Greenbelt
and is not in character with its
surroundings in consequence the Parish
Council objects on the grounds of one
over development of the site to impact
upon the adjacent four properties
three openness an impact upon the
Greenbelt and for creation of the
president replacing single depth
properties in country lanes with
properties of larger scale requiring
access and storage of a large number of
vehicles to the rear of the Trump
premises and in the process replacing
gardens and mature trees with tarmac or
other hard standing finally may I
comment that I believe the essence of
our objection is also every five seconds
occasions detailed report thank you
spot on thank you can you save just one
moment are there any questions
Celso fielding colleges on the parish
Town Council comment your last sentence
however if the officers conclude that
the application should be refused the
Parish Council with will withdraw in
what withdrawal what so I I don't
understand the question well the
question is what you've written has been
reported that you stated in our
documentation
John I don't think we need to go into
the no comment yeah it's fine thinking
are there any other questions for mr.
Rohan thank you very much indeed thank
you thank you we have our our next
speaker which is mr. Paul Humphries
there's a neighbor
I missed that mr. Andrew Ashcroft is are
you going to use it Oh half and half
one minute 30 seconds each yes to see
one of the other slides which is the
front okay wait could be a 10-second
warning when the one minute 30 seconds
is up
yes okay thank you very much my name's
Paul I'm Chris I live at Bray side which
is to the left of the property on that
picture there so on the north side which
means that any shading from the property
I get basically and I have three basic
objections which are just reiterations
of the written feedback you've had but
from a personal point of view I feel the
increase in size is immense something
like three times or four times the
actual floor living space in there in
building with garages as well or with
with our standing in the garden and the
positioning of the house is altered so
currently the height where the guttering
is to sit up but the second windows
there is something like 17 meters from
my fence on the new plan that same
height of building is only four meters
from my fence so it shifts the entire
property and its height to a much more
shading and dominating position over my
property what's left that four meters
then becomes a driveway potentially a
very noisy
well great increase in their
inconvenience for myself in terms of
noise and noise could be during the
night as well as during the day and then
different types of nuisance to me 10
seconds the a lot of light onto my the
room that I use on that side of the
property thank you thank you thank you
very much just to introduce my
properties to the rear perpendicular to
the proposed development and there's a
neighbor to mutilate I would reinforce
the comments made by the Planning Office
and parish council particularly
regarding the scale of increasing the
volume of the existing property and the
fact that the plan was proposed for 10
car parking spaces new car parking
spaces in the rear garden which will
lead to significant noise and light
disturbance throughout the day and
nighttime because the majority of arcing
spaces back on to our premises
I'm also joint chair of the Tanith
Neighborhood Development Plan and I
would also like to present relevant
information gathered whilst drafting
that NDP is going through the statutory
consultation phase at the minute but
from the survey which was circulated to
every household to inform the drafting
of that NDP 87 percent of respondents
were felt that flats and apartments were
not suitable in the parish and only 6
percent viewed them as suitable also
we've drafted the character of the area
within that NDP as a basis for
development and had a third party
planning consultant coming to write that
guidance in 10 seconds and their views
were low density of housing with
properties to setback with in deep
spacious plots and also the overall
sense of spaciousness
a key characteristic of the area thank
you very much indeed spot-on thank you
have please stay there for a moment
counselor kettle are just fair occasion
you said your house is perpendicular to
the rear on my Google Earth haven't got
a house behind this and are you long way
back I would say from the car parking
spaces our house is 40 40 50 yards from
the car parking spaces so you just
highlight it with the matter what so
ours is the one to the right of that
property where the cursor is that says
okay so we will get with we're putting
ARDS away from the parking space is
proposed our house but of course you'll
get the light pollution going across
from there have we any more questions no
more questions thank you very much
indeed thank you
they have a applicant now Vicki Porter
Potter
sorry Vicki Potter I'm so sorry that the
architect yeah you have six minutes
thank you very much I came me flayed as
you can see is a two-story house totally
screened from the street scene as you
can see on the slide here the planning
officer suggests refusing redevelopment
based on three policy areas which I will
address in turn firstly the Greenbelt
policy cs10 in order to comply with this
policy the proposal must be limited in
film in a local service village or
complete redevelopment of a previously
developed site subject to it not having
a materially greater impact on the
openness of the Greenbelt the definition
definition of limited and materially
greater impact are undefined and
therefore open to personal
interpretation or opinion next slide
please thank you that one um in my
professional view and that of our
planning consultant the development
would be both limited in scale and have
no materially greater impact than the
existing house critically maintaining
the significant open gaps to either side
of the property with a hip group that
slopes away from the boundary on both
sides it is contradictory the opposite
to state that the development is a small
scale and infill by definition but also
object on the basis of the building
being too large it's worth noting that
there are no percentage restrictions
applied to complete redevelopment for
site secondly the landscape policies cs5
and 12 I would like to clarify there is
no planning reason whatsoever to stop my
clients removing the trees to their
property
these policies relate to the openness of
the wider landscape and not the planting
schemes in our individual gardens the
design and associated tree removal will
notice notably improve the daylight to
brace ID in fact mr. Humphreys insurers
have already written to my clients
specifically requesting the removal of a
number of the existing trees due to
their proximity taste property all
landscape design and boundary
fencing would be robustly checked by the
planners as part of the reserved matters
application to ensure that the final
scheme has appropriate screening and
greenspace next slide please
thank you finally policy CHCs 9 which
relates to distinctiveness and design I
would reiterate that scale and
appearance are reserved matters the
officers report focuses on what the
detailed design may or may not be a
preserved matter stage rather than the
actual details of this outline
application which are layout and access
only the officer has no planning
objection it to apartments in principle
but believes that the proposed building
be out of character with the surrounding
area again this is a matter of
individual opinion and I strongly
disagree with the perp with the officers
personal view on this the building is
designed to appear as a large single
dwelling similar and in scale and height
to a number of other existing properties
on full head lane and broad lane as
shown on this picture Wood End has an
eclectic mix of housing and there are
substantial infill developments already
under construction along this road are
much more open and visible sights than
this next slide please
thank you the councillor and neighbor
mentioned the impact of the parking area
at the rear which I would note would be
gravelled and not tarmacked
the site is located opposite the golf
club which is shown on this picture this
Golf Club serves over 600 members at
night and through the evening the large
car park is permanently floodlit and
open all along pool head lane opposite
Mews laid and it's two adjacent
neighbors the additional impact of a
small number of cars on the new slate
site would quite clearly be negligible
in comparison and if we can jump onto
the next slide please I would draw the
committee's attention to two other
background parking areas marked on the
right here and just slightly further at
pool head lane which were not picked up
on the offices report I understand that
nobody wants building next to their
homes but the stark reality is that
Stratford requires 2,000 new rural homes
to be built within the Burroughs
villages
20:31 Woodend has been identified to
accommodate up to 32 of these to quote
the NDP building should be in
small-scale developments with less than
10 new homes with priority for two and
three bedrooms including those suitable
for residents wanting to downsize so
these proposed high-end apartments would
be marketed directly at this these local
dam sizes as suggested by the NDP in
fact the applicants themselves would
like to occupy one of the apartments and
two other long-term local residents have
already approached them expressing
interest in taking one emulate is the
perfect site to take some of these
much-needed smaller dwellings it's
located opposite the busy Golf Club in
the heart of the village walking
distance to the pub the Medical Centre
in the train station it's a previously
developed brownfield site an
intensification of the use is far better
than building on a virgin green site
it's one of the most well screen plots
in the area with extremely mature
planting to all the boundaries which
would be unchanged and it is almost
totally invisible from the street seen
behind a dense bank of conifers the
latest revision of the MPP F expressly
states that subdivision of the dwelling
house into smaller units is considered
appropriate development within the rural
area
despite Lee parish councilors comments
tonight the parish council had
previously logged in an October meeting
minutes that they had no planning reason
to objector seconds thank you and
furthermore they have actually only been
four neighbors objection from a parish
population of three thousand two of whom
are here tonight
living at the adjoining properties I
would just reiterate that the offices
objections are based on their own
definition of the word limited when it
comes to the scale of the infill and
each one of you will have your own
personal opinion on whether this
building would genuinely have a
materially great materially greater
impact on the Greenbelt than what is
already on this site thank you thank you
let's one of you stay there for a moment
are there any any questions councillor
kettle
you quote our core strategy on the
Greenbelt policy cs10 under Clause 4.1.2
there are two I think clauses which are
relevant which I'd like you just to help
me with the extensional alteration of a
building provider does not result in too
disproportionate additions over and
above the size of the original building
and then secondly these are the
exceptions which would allow development
in line with the NPP F the replacement
the replacement of the building
providing the new building is in the
same use and not mature a little larger
than the one it replaces now both those
clauses focus very much on size and the
points made by one of the earlier
speakers that this is a significantly
larger development than the one it is
looking to replace would you like to
help me with reconciling that position
okay so there are a number of different
clauses that this could fit into as part
of cs10 and we believe that it fits into
the subsection E which is the limited
info in the local service village there
is an a percentage rule related to
infill there are a number of
developments along the street where
there is a new building being put
between in gaps between buildings or one
buildings been replaced with three
further up the street so the definition
of whether it is it comes down to
whether this is limited and that's open
to interpretation
I did which answer the question
satisfactory counselor kennel thank you
I'm not quite sure what the two clauses
are specifically related to and clearly
you're correct it does have under there
bullet points not ABC but limited in
filling in accordance with the policy
sir and they're called strategy and I
think call strategy policy to which I
might need help from mr. Jeffery on this
one
it's probably a s10 where they'll be
community support but the points I
talked about was the same size not or
not above the original building that was
the area I used comment on I don't
actually have that precise wording to to
see if that's a policy that relates to
this okay thank you
councillor Jennings is it possible to go
back a couple of slides they've got one
with it so yes that one so that one
obviously on the existing at the run to
the bottom left it says ten and a half
meters and on the bottom right it's
thirteen and a half meters now except
because it's been we've had a lump
chopped out of it as such if you go and
it's difficult to point out can I point
to stand up and be the closest point to
the building to next for Novas now how
much closer is it roughly I mean I don't
know things like just about a meter but
the windows are further down the joy
where where the little writing is that
says
window where that dimension is taking
across so where the buildings are
closest either side of the drive there
were no habitable windows on the gray
side that's their garage and yeah there
are no habit that would be unlikely to
be any windows from the new building
onto that driveway okay I'm trying to
get an idea in my head is how much
closer sort of its expanded out and how
much closer ocation actually the
distances and spec we can do that
obvious clarification okay Kelso
fielding referred to the fact that there
have been a request to remove certain
trees for by the neighbor are these
because of the size of the trees and
affecting his light or are they because
they're damaging his property due to the
route activity my clients received a
letter from the neighbors insurers
recommending the removal of some of the
trees because of the proximity to their
property for route damage I believe as
far as I understand it one of the trees
has already come down as requested there
were more that could potentially be
removed and there are a number that when
looking to remove as part of this
application where that driveway runs
between the two buildings it's not the
trees aren't protected it's not
conservation area so they can be removed
as agreed between the neighbors there's
no TPL on them yeah
yeah thank you ma'am
any other questions no thank you very
much indeed thank you but is there more
than men who don't speak he's not
speaking it's too close
oh yeah yeah I think well I can see you
there counselor dick summer you're not
speaking okay it's okay we got two
points of clarification now it was
question possible to go to mr. Nash the
ward numbers response requesting it goes
to committee I was going to ask him as
to why he felt that with news that he's
not he's not the way to go because I was
of the opinion that we have to give a
planning reason for coming against the
officers recommendation we haven't got
your committee yeah well we have Peter
we have gone to the debate yet we offers
a clarification the moment the committee
committee I have to give a a valid
reason for my opinion Peter just my man
please Mesa thank you the actual
application is here because the head of
planning was request counsel Dixon that
actually has confirmed because of where
he lives there may be a conflict that
there may be an issue with him speaking
that's why councillor Dixon is not
speaking as a board member tonight and
adjoining councillor can speak for him
but he has to appoint one yes there is
ones here
choice of clarification counselor
feeling well are we on points of
clarification now jolly good
in the course of dealing with this
development or this outline development
have you taken into account anything to
do with the problems associated with the
trees around the property and the
effects they may be having so we're
considering access and layout and the
principal of the development at this
stage not the final landscaping
associated with the development that the
access does show that a number of mature
trees would need to be removed
I believe the approximately eight to
provide the access we've considered the
application based on the principle the
access and the layout and officers have
raised concerns about the impact of the
development on the neighboring
properties we've considered the layout
in its current form the landscaping is
is a later consideration in full
thank you councillor kettle the
applicants agent was sort of referring
to this being quite a significant house
well-designed etc and I was trying to
find it in the NPP fi news number in the
old NPP F and I can't find at the new
NPP F and we have had the discussion
before about properties which by being
exceptional in nature should receive a
sort of positive support obviously nine
with other policies would this
application and the polluters at outline
stage would it meet the criteria of
being an exceptional design or I'm sure
David here the one I'm talking about I
just can't find it yeah the councillors
referring to paragraph 79 of the NPP F
which allows for isolated dwellings in
the countryside if the design is of
exceptional quality
this fails that in a number of respects
firstly being that it's not isolated
during the countryside as my colleague
was talking about before we are here
today to consider the outline proposal
just for access and layout there is
nothing within those details provided to
us that suggests that this is an
exceptional desiring quality so it
wouldn't fall to be considered on the
paragraph 79 at the NPP F Kelso Jenny
Jeon I think you were yes so I've taken
a measurement and approximate
measurement from if we go back this
point here over and across possibly nine
point six meters so from the side
elevation of the neighbor over to the
closest part okay so the closest is nine
points nine point six meters so from the
side elevation of the neighboring
property here over to the closest part
here of the Vallejo that's proposed
hurdles I know it better quicker the
agent has referred to the need to
deliver the 2,000 houses in court in the
LS fees I know we have the latest
publication in July of the five-year
housing land supply what is the position
in relation to to the roof homes within
LS fees across the district
very positive the council has you know
healthy five-year housing land supply
and the local service villages
contribute to that in respective
category for local service villages of
which would end is one we've had a total
of four hundred and twelve dwellings
delivered against the approximate target
a total of four hundred
that looks out about 32 each let us say
these are guidance their targets their
approximate targets within the core
strategy would end has delivered four
and committed a further seven so it has
11 at the moment so officers consider
housing requirement to be a strong
argument in favor of the development
albeit than the NPP Africa's guide us
towards boosting the supply of homes but
nor would it weigh against it
there certainly appears to be capacity
in would end and this is within the
built a barrier boundary where we would
seek to support new dwellings being
delivered ordinarily thank you David
anybody point someone clarification yeah
can we go to the debate who would like
to counselor bones yes um the big house
in the Greenbelt is has to be for a
special reason
obviously the reason is we got
accommodation which we haven't got in
the village if people understand me and
we can see the thoughts but I really do
feel that the offices recommendation
this charm is correct and whether the
effect on the neighbors the effect on
the area the car parking I think is
unacceptable so long cord happy to
propose refusal there's a proposal was
it thank you
is anybody else me Calvin Fleming I've
got a couple of concerns and it's in a
similar thing to Peters if you look at
the existing plans
apart from removing trees that are
necessary for safety purposes I Eve like
we were talking earlier about
some whatever and we've got this climate
emergency where we've got to try and
keep as many trees standing as we can
and there has to be a really good reason
to be taking trees down when so I don't
like it from that perspective do the
thing I have a little bit of a problem
with it so for me to drive and the
length of the drive I think we certainly
mean drivers four meters wide I think
all the way up the back there so if
somebody in the back of that car part
starts to come down and somebody's
coming in there's potentially an issue
there so I I don't particularly like it
from that perspective and like I say the
other issue is as well as the the
massive increase in volume with saying
okay it's only a few meters wider and a
few meters deeper whatever else but look
at the volume compared to the original
house
I think it's significantly bigger to be
a problem
councillor feeling the comment from the
the neighbor was the fact that shade
would affect their property being on the
north side of this property on the other
hand there are a lot of from what I
gather the largest trees I think I'm
very much in two minds on this one we we
need some small houses and small units
but I'll see what everybody else says
Thank You councillor Fiona
I'm sorry Celtic kettle so sorry I think
the proposal as it stands is has merit I
think it is delivering clearly what
may be needed across the district we
often hear about we see too many big
houses standing alone four or five
bedroom houses and not enough one two or
even three bedroom houses and here we do
have a proposal going forward that is
for a series of flats which provide
accommodation for those who don't to buy
a full house I'm not persuaded though I
accept would end has had four homes
already built in a7 which have gone
through the Planning Commission so there
is a shortfall but the question I I was
looking for is that the LS fees we have
now delivered more than the two thousand
that the architect agent referred to I
think we're about two and on earth
nearly two and a half thousand have now
been delivered so we're not under
pressure from housing in terms of
delivery in the LS fees albeit in this
LS fee we clearly are short but you're
always going to get a distribution
between other LS fees so I don't think
that argument carries significant weight
given where we are in terms of our a
five-year housing and supply but B the
fact as I said earlier on in front of me
LS fees which should be delivering two
thousand we've actually delivered at the
core strategy time sorry at the five
years events like ovation 2400 so we
then get to the proximate I think as the
green belt we've heard this doesn't
classify under what was section five or
seven seventy five now 79 this is not an
exceptional home I think it's actually a
prettier house than what it currently
exists but if we go back to the various
clauses in the NPP F and I'm sorry and I
haven't got all the different changes
that you you rather raise through and
Iran there's a very significant section
yet referring to what is acceptable
within the green belt and the two I
pointed out which we were something on
the same site are more or less the same
size and in fact we didn't have exact
some of the case in our training we had
some a couple of months ago this is a
significantly bigger development it is
not supported by the Parish Council it
wouldn't therefore fall into meeting
community of the needs of the community
as represented so although I think it's
nicely designed and I think it's a sort
of property that we might need I think
it's in the wrong place it is in the
green belt and therefore I cannot
support the application going head
therefore I would be minded to be too
followed mr. Barnes was his
recommendation so we proposed from
officers recommendation from councillor
bouncer
seconded by Councillor kettle yeah I
think it's a good looking property but
it's just in the wrong place fine thank
you
right you can we we so can we go to the
so I pretty much have the same feelings
there's a I'm all for splitting up these
big houses which when you've got wasn't
family and so may only have one two
people in them when you need when there
is a demand for the three-bedroom or
two-bedroom flats but I say this just
seems to be
right can we come we go to the votes
that will be supporting the officers
recommendation yes sorry yes it's
actually refused the application do we
have a vote on that
no thank you
all those in favor
thank you the council resolves to refuse
the application thank you
thank you we've come to our second item
the agenda to this evening its
[Music]
application 19 oblique 0 2 0 6 4 oblique
fel and 19 0 to 0-5 for oblique lbc it's
for chest up farm
Jill Lane Sanborn and we haven't got
anybody from Parish Council or objectors
but we do have the applicant oh I'm so
sorry yes I'm going ahead of myself so
that they stay at David thank chair as
you said this is application 19 oblique
zero two zero six four slash ful and
application 19/2 zero six five slash LBC
chestnut farm G Elaine Sanborn the
applicant is seeking planning permission
unless they build a consent for the
change of use of the farm house and
lower bond to create four dwellings two
in each building this slide shows the
application site west of Studley and
north of Sanborn the site lays in the
west midland Greenbelt and within the
Arden SLA this slide shows the
application site outlined in red the
main farmhouse identified with the
orange dot is a grade 2 listed building
the barns to its east here our curtilage
listed current use of both properties is
as offices however they're both
currently vacant this aerial photograph
shows the wider context of the site
sitting in its open countryside location
this closer aerial view shows the
farmhouse in the barns sitting within
the wider complex of chestnut court
which is a Business Park predominantly
office uses and other industrial and
takings
the aerial view is slightly dated in
that there is an access Drive now
through this area here towards the
farmhouse and the barns this slide shows
the details of previous permission and
listed building consent which was
granted in 2017 this permitted a change
of use to three units two shown in green
and blue within the barn and the farm
house staying as a single unit the
garden area associated with the
farmhouse remaining as a single whole
and the parking areas to the rear of the
farmhouse remaining much the same as
they exist today this slide shows the
proposal before members tonight it
proposes for dwellings within the two
main buildings two in the main farmhouse
and two in the barn
this would additionally require the
subdivision of the garden as shown by
this boundary treatment and alterations
to the parking area in here the
farmhouse would comprise one three
bedroom property and one four bedroom
property and the barn would comprise one
two-bedroom property and a-one their
dwelling this plan shows that 2017
approved floor plans for the farmhouse
is a single unit and this shows the
proposal before members tonight the red
lines highlighting the subdivision of
the property this plan shows both the
2017 approved scheme for the barn and
alongside it the scheme under
consideration tonight the dotted red
lines here show the subdivision of that
barn the elevations of the property are
largely unchanged from the existing so
I'll show those through
a number of photographs this photograph
shows the view from jail lane looking
towards the western elevation of the
farmhouse the new access which wasn't
visible on the aerial view is shown
before coming in here
the main farmhouse here the garden which
is proposed to be subdivided in front of
us and then to the rear at the farmhouse
in this view would be the bounds a
closer view and taking the winter less
foliage on the trees reveals the front
elevation of the listed building this
view from the rear shows the eastern
elevation of the farmhouse the areas of
parking and landscaping sitting between
the farmhouse and the barns which are to
be converted the conversion takes in
three bays here that you can see
including the timber framed this unit
and that unit to be converted into two
dwellings this is also a listed building
as part of the wider employment uses on
the site it remains be one office uses
and this photo shows the rear elevation
of the barns with the kick rail fence
before us which would approximate the
boundary of any gardens
development plan policy in respective
listed buildings requires
decision-makers to secure the optimum
viable use for listed buildings in this
case the loss of character which would
arise from the subdivision of the
farmhouse into two dwellings has not
been justified in offices view it would
be more harmful in offices view than the
extant 2017 consent which allows one
dwelling but would not accrue any
additional public benefits the
applicants have argued that the division
into two is necessary for viability
reasons the officers are not satisfied
that the submitted details are robust as
they include works which have not been
approved by the
existing consent accordingly officers
are not satisfied that the development
amounts to the optimum viable use and
have recommended refusal for the reasons
before you in the agenda Thank You chair
thank you David
but this were we haven't got any parish
council speakers or objectors but we do
have the applicant for you Gary Moss and
Peter waters from they would grab
developments how you going to split this
up welcome back Gary thank you okay
right as I set out by your officer
Planning Commission has already been
granted to convert these commercial
units into residential development that
remains the fundamental position and the
for that position all we are now seeking
is effectively the subdivision of the
farm house which has consent as a
seven-bedroom property which as you've
seen from surrounding land and the
presentation next to a business park
next to this road in this location is
just not really suitable for my ver
marketing point of view or more
importantly from the policies in the
development plan which seats for smaller
family housing which this scheme
provides it actually provides one to bed
to three bed and one for bed property
which is fully in accordance with the
council's own housing mix you'll also
note from the report the conservation
officers is agreed with the clients own
heritage officer that this proposal
provides a simple cleaner light touch
sympathetic conversion it preserves the
physical layout of the building whilst
there is a viability and
it's analysis that's been undertaken
that's been supported by two independent
estate agents confirming that a seven
bed farmhouse in this location just
would not be soluble hence the reason to
subdivide it the Civic division is also
practical from the layout of the
building there are two staircases and
given its former office use a lot of the
original subdivision partition walls has
been removed and made a far cleaner
better building in terms of the public
benefits and this is must being like
there the harm to the listed building is
minimal as stated by the conservation
officer we have better housing mix less
traffic it brings this building back
into active use and it's historically
already got sent for residential use
we've worked with the council to reduced
any impact on the list of building and
in particular with the curtilage barn
that's been reverted back from what was
proposed as a free bedroom property back
to a two-unit scheme and some of the
other issues that have been raised in
terms of the subdivision of the garden
we are looking at a simple post and rail
fence for subdivision that is already
characteristic of the area and
ultimately this has both parish and ward
member support again the benefits of
providing to family units over that of
one large house I think members you
briefly discussed it in the last item
you know the NBP F is now clear that
actually they are actively seeking the
subdivision of larger properties into
smaller properties which meet current
demand and I think we've all sinned over
time as a pressing need in Stratford for
this type of family home any questions
were happy to help thank you very much
it's
spot-on councillor fielding do any idea
of the age of the two buildings I
actually haven't got them to hand the
officers may have the plan we did submit
a detailed analysis of how the building
has evolved the earliest parts we
believe date from the 16th century and
then it goes been extended and altered
throughout up until the 19th century
when it was converted into offices much
of the date of the office conversion
yeah if you look back at the floor plans
if the officers have the floor plans
where we proposed a subdivision so the
farm of the firehouse apologies you'll
see the two sets of staircases so
there's a natural split and because of
its uses offices a lot of those rooms
have been split and subdivided
historically we're actually bringing it
back into a more original state or be it
as two units rather than the historical
widen unit that was thanks thanks very
much very good yes used to go up for the
servants quarters in the roof space or
are they put in there since the office
blocks so I'm currently into the scheme
you've got lots and lots of obviously
fire doors it was I think he was seven
individual offices originally and there
are two very clear staircases one of
them in the more modern side is almost
like a modern fire escape but it is its
own separate sort of stairwell so to
speak and the reason why we've done that
is because one side is half timbered one
side is brick the same with the barns as
well we're actually splitting them
logically of where the two Ages were
visibly different as well you looking at
me councillor kettle
I haven't quite got a stage but you
forced me but you have the splits on the
ground floor is different in the main
house is different special than the
first floor because you looking at the
drawings we have you got a dogleg on the
ground floor and you've got a right
angle space on the top floor yes
originally and we actually did them both
in line with a dogleg and then the
advice from the conservation was to
include that part with with the other
building so on the original first
submitted plans we did include them both
together and then following the site
visits they preferred it on this layout
the question was actually going to ask
but Matt had the map in front of it sort
of appropriate you say the NPP F
supports the diffusion of larger scale
properties I wasn't aware that could you
point me where that might be yeah if you
mentioned its section of paragraph 79
which again relates to isolated
dwellings but if you read paragraph 79
in context of rural housing as a concept
I wouldn't necessarily say to dwelling
in order for subdivision to be accepted
and the main reason I say that at the
moment is the development plan for
Stratford is actually silent on this
because it's a very recent addition to
the NPP I think was never part of the
original NPP F when Stratford obviously
adopted its core strategy
so the mtbf relates it to rural housing
including that of where it was an
isolated welling but for the purposes of
creating the public benefits that we've
outlined the subdivision is now a
national policy requirement Thanks
thank you thank you
anymore point caliban's yes when the
opposite did his presentation there was
a bomb agricultural on and that's not
relevant for this application this is
all to do with the site itself contains
two buildings so the great enlisted
farmhouse which we're looking to
subdivide into two it has a consent to
be back into one dwelling and then the
curtains listed barn which again was
offices is now being proposed to be
converted into two residential units
which was previously accepted under the
2017 application okay sorry
clarify because because the original
application was done as one we were
requested to submit it as one again so
we have to include the barns within the
application okay thank you very much
thank you no other points thank you very
much indeed thank you right we have the
board member now thank you
you have five minutes
Thank You chair I won't need them thank
you very much mr. chairman this
application has support from both the
parish council and ward member and as I
mentioned in my own supporting comments
I believe the plan as a whole represents
an amicable and sensitive compromise
application there is a local need for
two three and four-bedroom properties in
the area and bringing an empty property
back into service albeit a listed one
with minimal and light touch changes as
highlighted by the Heritage consultant
seems to be a sound and sympathetic
approach to addressing that need the
site is brownfield and and the proposal
has no impact on the Greenbelt or its
openness and given the fact there's no
requirement to a desire for a large 7
bed welling especially in the location
adjacent to erode an existing business
park and that a location will change
from a commercial office back to
residential use
that the public benefits clearly
outweigh the minimal harm that this
application may cause I don't believe
that its continued use or reuse and
office is desirable realistic or
practical and the schemes local support
shows that a large country house isn't
required or preferred by village
residents our remit as members in the
light of the climate emergency is to
carefully consider the environmental
impact of any development and equally
what the impact of not allowing and
development is an unusable office or an
unsalable large dwelling left to stand
empty is not putting practical or best
use to the unused assets that we have as
a district of course we must consider
the harm to precious ones but to my mind
this application strikes a good balance
between our primary considerations and
the benefits it offers I therefore ask
that members please grant this
application thank you thank you very
much any questions for the board member
councillor kettle you say not quite in
your words but you say effective it's an
empty empty redundant property what
evidence have you got that it has been
marketed property it's me personally
that's not a question I can entirely
answer with a a great deal of accuracy
that's more one that the applicant would
have presented as part the application
I'm afraid
any more questions for the world member
council Kelly are you still thinking yes
I am
if I look at the conservation officers
response one I'm looking at reply
summary object harm arising from the
principle of the works to subdivide the
farmhouse to crate to residential units
that's not hugely indicative of support
if at the opening line the earthly words
object which part of the report you're
looking at sorry I'm looking at the
conservation officers response dated
14th of August in relation to chestnut
farms you'll then sample I don't have
that in front of me I'll be honest but
no thank you no more questions
Thank You councillor my freak-outs your
points of clarification now
councilor Jennings just so I've got this
right um the officer is okay with you're
okay with the bonds being converted yes
in principle we don't have a concern
with the proposals for the bonds and
they're very similar to those that were
approved in 2017 okay and you'll be okay
we're switching it it's currently in
office but you're happy to convert that
back to a seven-bedroom house as the
report sets out the loss of employment
uses has already been found acceptable
in the 2017 application for both of
these buildings so we we don't have a
concern in that respect either so you're
happy with the house yes just you wanted
to remain one house as opposed to being
split up so the concern arises in
respective the main farmhouse the
conservation officer is largely content
as the applicant says with the impact of
the proposal on the fabric of the
farmhouse the harm arises because the
building is a single dwelling was built
as a single dwelling in the mid 16th
century and the change in character and
significance of the building as a single
dwelling by converting it into two
results in less than substantial harm to
the significance of that building we are
charged with considering what is the
optimum viable use this has a permission
for one dwelling and the applicants
through the process of this application
have not managed to convince officers
that the converting it into one is not
feasible and they would like us to agree
that converting it into two is the only
viable use and that is therefore the
optimum use however the information
provided has not convinced us of that
and they declined the opportunity to
have it assessed by a third-party
independent Assessor thank you very much
council feeling
it would appear that there's going to be
quite a lot of internal work being done
to take away the far doors and
everything else that has been associated
with it as an office surely if the work
is being carried out isn't that going to
more or less leave it open to bringing
it into the state that the applicant is
putting it into I'm not quite sure what
the question is I think I just reiterate
my point that the conservation office is
happy with the impact on the fabric of
the building itself is about the impact
on the character and the significance
that the character of the building has
to our understanding of it suited kind
to me when questioned about dividing it
I think it's fair to say the changes
would not be insignificant but the
conservation officer is happy that
historic fabric within the building
would not be harmed
it's it's to do with the character and
the significance of it as a single
dwelling farmhouse which would be lost
in which in offices views has not been
justified councillor Flemming in the
original permission where it's going to
be a single dwelling how many bedrooms
was it was in the end that permission
that it got for the single dwelling
because I mean the guys were talking
about seven bedrooms but it's seven
offices you're not gonna have I'm
assuming if they're gonna strip some out
there's going to be less bedrooms and
seven when it was converted into one
property the applicant said seven in
their presentation and I don't dispute
that
sorry calcic Hetal
I mean it's all about the conservation
issue and therefore going back through
the conservation officers report he does
say home and he does say relating to
subdivision ok can you ask a question
then yeah possibly fathers debate yeah
thanks thank you how will future Kelly
now goes to the debate then who would
counsel Jennings their conservation
officer said that there's going to be
harm and I guess it's up to us now to
judge how much harm whether it's going
to be unjustified harm or whether it's
going to be justified harm I think what
councilor fielding was trying to get at
was there obviously if we're going to
it's going to be gutted whether when
they put it back together again where
this together is it going to be much
difference with one house or two and
again that's I guess where we're where
we have to sit in and work out and
judged weighing up whether how much loss
of character is there whether there's an
unacceptable loss of character or
whether there's a justifiable amount of
loss yeah I think it's more that you
know the policy drives you towards
considering whether this is the optimum
viable use for the development officers
are concerned that that hasn't been
demonstrated so it's not really judging
whether the benefits outweigh the harm
it's about whether this is the most
suitable viable use for that particular
building in terms of conservation sorry
John Kelso kettle
I find this kind of corporate because I
think you know if one looks at the
overall sight you've got quite a
significant industrial part behind it
and this quite substantial listed former
dwelling house is sort of slightly
isolated from its natural environment by
having this big industrial park at the
back so one side of me says well does it
really matter because at the end of the
day the fabric of the building will be
maintained as the conservation officer
said but as mr. Jeffrey has clearly
pointed out it's the principle about
splitting a dwelling house in this
situation into two once you've done it
you can go back but whether it will
really work and if you look at the the
way the house it sets out the barns it
really works well because it's a long
thin line into putting a dividing line
straight through the middle and
therefore that is not an unfamiliar way
of converting performance tables or
whatever into dwelling houses but this
is very different it's an l-shape and
they're not even splitting it so
straight down the middle you've got a
sort of cockeyed bit in the middle and
then you've got the idea especially in
the garden out which it looks really
uncomfortable and if we were talking
about a non listed building I wouldn't
really have a problem but this is a
listed building and as mr. Jeffrey has
clearly pointed out we're looking for an
optimal solution and the optimal
solution is that there is already an
approval for splitting the barns
although this is a better division
according to conservation officer than
the previous one so that's that is a
bonus but the offset is you know his
wording is harm to significant will
arise from the principle of the work
still stands it's not terribly well
worded but he is the conservation
officer mostly she in this case very
clearly does have an issue with
splitting a property
and we've not been allies understand
from things said earlier we haven't been
given evidence that there's been a major
marketing campaign to sell this property
as a standalone property and the reason
market one only looks through the very
glossy brochures of samples and like
Frank all these other firms where they
are regularly marketing significant
seven-bedroom or something similar
properties how do we evidence that this
has been on the market from in years and
nobody had taken it up then I think
we've been a different position but we
got a we've got an optimum solution
which the conservation officer is happy
with which brings our property back into
use of domestic residents this is a step
away from that and there's no evidence
to suggest that this needs to be done
because it can't be sold as a standalone
property so I'm I'm absolutely minded to
go with your recommendation on this one
councillor Barnes yes I'm a bit of a
different opinion in the respect that
the house has got to be saved
I've got a a big hands fighters in my
ward that went into offices are Potamus
empty it's looking in a bad way no
heating or whatever so in the
perspective usually for residential I my
personal opinion feel that this is quite
a good scheme obviously there's going to
be less traffic and it will become in a
different time which one would be a good
thing but the road there but she's
bummed up with trapping anyway so I
think it's a good reuse of the building
a lot of works got to be done because
it's been opposite but I think it will
bring it back to his glory so I could
support
Thank You Pete I think we too happy that
we granted on the grounds we've got the
ward member behind it the amount of work
that's going to take place within the
building I think is going to be
considerable there are two staircase is
already in 6u one is a modern one so if
you're going to put it back into a
seven-bedroom house you'll probably have
to take a modern staircase out to give
it the features that a seven-bedroom
house of this age would require I
believe that it's it's a it's a good
scheme for building that's in the wrong
place because of the industry behind and
I therefore going against the officers
so that I will you second yep proposal
by councillor kettles second it by
against I'm sorry I'm so sorry you're
quite right I have put a proposal that
we accept the office right now so sort
of fuse that has yet to be seconded if
anybody is interested in second even if
they're not interested second it them
the proposal halls go second that
proposal
don't lose it
[Music]
can I just come back mr. field has made
a number of comments about I think which
I think are assumptions about what might
or might not happen inside about
removing staircases or whatever we
haven't got any information about that
what would need to be done if it is
retained as a building house I think we
need to be very careful about the
evidence that we use making that
decision we haven't got that information
we don't know
so to interject counselor the
information on screen now is the 2017
approval of the farmhouse as a single
unit
in respect to the particular matters
which councillor fielding raised you can
see that the approval identifies two
staircases to remain no change thank you
so much do all they can to illustrate
what it could be like so you have a
person to accept the refuse I propose to
accept the officers recommendation and
she's trying proposal if there's been a
second day bye bye mr. living in a safe
by mr. Payne right we took a picture can
we have votes on that those in favor
from those against
right yeah proposed for so we open up
the proposal now so who posed by
Councillor fielding ii apply that we
said that we support the applicant yes
as we has been able need some raisins
and also nuclear for the conditions as
well yeah speaking sorry
yes thank you mesa go please ask members
to briefly discuss reasons for some
supporting the proposal 10 it's open
countryside it needs to just find the
right this is 10 s sorry me labels are
coming away residential small scale
including of the redevelopment of
buildings within the built up it was not
within the built up area boundary
conversion of residential buildings with
physical contrast or a village at C and
D is a redundant building present use
were redundant or disused building in
open countryside you've also got a s CS
one which is in and should be taken into
account that it should be granted which
is a nine
here's the ones I've written down hi
Lance 9 it's it's it's distinctive as a
building it should be made to be used
for residential use so that goes against
the office usage and I think it
internally it's an innovative design if
that answers some questions there's a
bar sorry I was just going to suggest
perhaps members would like to consider
policy cs8 in respect of whether this is
the optimum viable use I think the other
thing mr. chairman is with the listed
building if the application doesn't have
substantial harm which I don't think
this is I think that that's one reason
to support the they've just referred to
CS 8 councillor kettle fully accept my
proposal has fallen but I think we do
have to be very careful once again about
the facts we used to oppose the offices
recommendation this at the site has
already been approved for conversion
from an office to a domestic residents
it is therefore that argument is no
longer relevant because the planning
permission has been given for it my
stomach we've now just I'm just saying
we do need to be very careful the second
thing we've been told it's a redundant
building we've got no evidence as
redundant building it hasn't it's been
converted always the process being
converted to domestic residents no what
no one has had it's been redundant so I
think we need to be very careful about
use of language I thought we were
looking at reasons approved by the
opposite and the solicitor for us to
vote on
no you're trying to provide me with
reasons to support the application I'm
directing you towards policy CS 8 which
says that this needs to be the optimum
viable usable members for seeing that
you may wish to overturn officers
recommendation I briefly put together a
number of conditions I propose that for
the full application members consider
the need for a condition restricting the
time period which the application should
be implemented plans which it relates
samples of materials for replacements of
any extensions details of hard and soft
landscaping including boundary
treatments parking to be implemented
prior to the occupation of the buildings
provision of wheelie bins provision of
water books provision of an electric
vehicle charging point and removal of
any PD rights relating to classes - part
1 classes ABCDE and G and part 2 Class A
for the listed building consent we would
recommend counselors consider the need
for a condition that Italy implemented
within three year time period condition
for plans to which the decision relates
samples of materials large scale plans
of joinery and architectural details for
new windows in the farmhouse dining room
and replacement extension and existing
and proposed trust sections to be
provided proposed services plans to
include new flues vents and extractors
in addition we would recommend that
delegated be power delegated powers be
and that granted to officers to agree
further conditions as necessary with the
chair and the final wording of any can
and delegated to officers as well
conditions their work and counsel yeah
yeah just one additional suggested
condition and that is given the two
properties if it is approved assuages
will be in close proximity to each other
there is discussion about the form of
fencing between the two gardens and I
think that needs to be done
sympathetically both to ensure that the
immunity of each separate garden is is
robust but also the fencing is
commensurate with the setting which is
in a list of building and that should be
either delegated who asked us to to
implement or in association with the
chair yes I agree with everything you've
said there counselor kettle I think it
would be captured by our ordinary
condition for the details of hard and
soft landscaping and whereby we
ordinarily seek details of boundary
treatments and the removal of any PD
rights and in part to class a would mean
that there wouldn't be a permitted
development right for replacement fences
to be erected without the consent of the
planning authority so any P permitting
development rights on the listed
building would it depends Council bars
counselor field and happy with that good
good
my practice in a second vote on this
name application first you
the proposal is to approve the
application full application project
konichiwa chestnut hub oh sorry
reference Han quite right nineteen
oblique zero two zero six for ably ful
in the recent conditions on that Street
chairman abstentions the committee
confirms to support this application
never going to nail the list it building
is one line oblique zero two zero six
five oblique LBC you're happy so we've
done that those all those in favor G
all those in favor against abstentions
two three abstentions its proposed
discontent thank you
now resolved thank you
by mr. Moss right well tell oh yes we've
now withdrawn as the application number
nineteen oblique zero one nine four
seven of Liddy ful home beam house
number one Brook Street Finney Compton
the application has been withdrawn as
detailed in the updated sheet thank you
we come to our final application on the
agenda which is application number one
nine oblique zero two zero four to the
ful land adjacent to field and in Winton
Road arms constructive on Aven Herron
who's a presenting officer thank you
thank you Joe the application site lies
to the west of arms code settlement I've
identified by the black dot on this plan
arms Kurt identified within the adopted
cross chastity isn't all of the
settlements site also lies within the
veil of easy visceral control this slide
identifies the application site outlined
in red the site lie to the north of the
ill Menton Road and comprises an
existing outbuilding just here and an
area to the south planning permission is
sought the conversion of the existing
outbuilding to a one bedroom dwelling
closes neighboring property lies to the
north and the West field and located
here to the south line neighboring
properties across the road and to the
east of the sites a car park area here
and a building with office use there are
a number of listed buildings in the
wider area which are shown in red
shading on this plan this slide shows an
aerial image of the application site
which is outlined in red you see here
field end over over here and you've got
the car parking area and the building to
the right and neighboring properties
along to the south with the ill needing
road
between this flight is proposed floor
plans and elevations for the building
the main changes externally on the front
elevation where you'll be getting fake
carriage doors here carriage doors here
pedestrian access a new window in
existing hatch area and roof flights
internally at ground floor you have
pedestrian access up to the staircase
with a bedroom and shower room and
you've also got a garage to the right
hand side just here with bin storage
which is accessed by an external garage
door you can see just here to the south
that first floor level you've got an
open plan living area with sitting room
area dining area and kitchen area and a
separate toilet this slide shows a
photograph looking north towards your
application building you can see here
the existing garage doors and hatch at
first floor where the new window is
proposed this photograph is looking
towards the application building you can
see here to the right-hand side of the
image is a car parking area got the foot
way along the young team road and the
access to neighboring properties just
beyond the building this photograph is
taken looking across the road from the
application site towards an app which is
this dwelling here it just happens
Capitol windows full sorry habitable
windows on the front elevation and
Willow corner beyond this photograph is
taken from the application building see
the access to the neighboring property
here the application buildings to the
right and the neighboring properties
across the road are shown to the left of
the image this abode crabs are looking
back towards the application site the
building is just here on the left the
building beyond there's a fuzzy dirt pub
just beyond as well with the neighboring
properties along the southern boundary
of the in Lincoln Road and this
photograph is taken with a building on
the right-hand side and the access to
field end which goes round with a garage
here and you can see the main building
here on the plan proposal is considered
to have an adverse impact on the amenity
of neighboring properties by reason of
overlooking estate and is considered to
result in harm to highway safety does
therefore recommended that planning
permission is refused to the reasons
outlined in the officer report thank you
Thank You Aaron thank you um
might we come we haven't got to bash
your Town Council's objects as we've had
the applicant Stuart no father has from
having missing phone you have three
minutes press the middle button
development suggesting that it would
improve arm scope we engaged sddc
prior to instructing an architect and
other consultants the duty planner
indicated that the principle of
development would be acceptable along
with the lack of outdoor amenity space
in regards to the challenges overlooking
the point of the roof lysis let natural
light into the main living space the
roof lights would be positioned 1.6
meters off the floor making overlooking
neighbors difficult in a practical sense
as you can only look towards the horizon
there are existing roof lights
overlooking fields end discussion held
with owner-occupiers of Willow corner
who have no objection and the distance
is actually approximately 0.5 meters
over the minimum required separation
distance of 30 metres if measured from
the bedroom window garage size is
approximately three and a half by six
meters which is about 14% smaller than
the SDC requirement is that material if
we go to the first slide the the public
house the fuzzy duck is the main cause
of of issues within arm scope as you can
see from the first slide staff regularly
park outside of the of the public house
and if we move to the second slide which
is later in the day at one o'clock in
additional three carts have arrived all
three of those counts of regular cars in
the neighborhood who belong to the staff
of the pub and if we move on to the
third slide it clearly illustrates on
the right-hand side along the road
towards element in the overspill from
the pub car park which doesn't have
enough space for the amount of seating
available all houses apart from the nap
have off street parking for at least one
car at the front and rear of their
houses and all
the drives the drivers reversed
typically onto the road the benefits of
the scheme that it's a sympathetic
inconsistent reuse of a historical
building we engaged a local architect to
ensure that the scheme has values the
community by optimizing the use of the
building proposing the upside bailout
the attractiveness visual impact of the
building will be approved for example
the asbestos roof will be replaced
without the development there is risk
that the building deteriorates it will
provide a single bed dwelling which will
benefit first time or local residents
looking to borrow reasonable cost
adding an unusual building to diversity
of the housing stock it is a sustainable
development utilizing existing building
fabric with minimal changes lowering
carbon intensity the conversion will
attract a CIO levy of five thousand
pounds and SVTC will receive council tax
income rather than zero business rates
as today our interests are aligned with
those in the village since we live there
we wouldn't have proposed it if we
didn't think the scheme had that benefit
thank you very much
any any questions there councillor Vance
you on about roof lights can you be more
relevant in the respective they don't
want roof much so there are proposal
contains four roof lights two of which
were existing and the concern that the
planets raised is that you would be able
to overlook neighboring properties the
roof lights are about 1.6 meters off the
ground I'm about one meter eighty tall
which means I would have to stand on my
tippy toes to look out yeah well not to
be looking towards the horizon so are we
looking across the road or at the back
as well yes we would flip to the there
would be two roof lights on the building
on that image there and then there would
be two bikes replacing the existing
yes okay yes maybe - do you or is it
open now you elaborate you know I
understand where we're going apologies
for not picked it
Celso tearing the concern I have is that
of the building extending over the
footpath or do you actually use the
current doors and if you do open the
doors do they cross over the footpath
and are they therefore dangerous as far
as highways yep so if we were to flip to
an image of the the front of the of the
building you can see that the council
earlier in the year installed some blue
stones just next to the new tarmac in
front of the building so the typically
the car on the left-hand side is my
mother-in-law's car
so she's not normally parked in there
but we typically Park on on the tarmac
leaving the blue stones available for
persons to walk on we currently do store
a classic car in in in the barn which
comes out on on weekends and to exit the
band The Doors need to be swung open but
typically there's not much traffic along
the bluestones because there's normally
confusion about whether that is a
footpath and actually the vast majority
of people I see walking towards the pub
use the use of the main road and I
myself when I'm walking to the main road
thank you just to confirm you don't own
the strip of land outside the building
we we own the foot we own the footprint
of the building right so we don't own
any of the land around it um it is part
of our early inquiries we approached
both feel then and the neighboring land
to seeking to acquire a portion of the
land but they said no okay
thank oh hello you say about the garage
being 14% smaller than our requirements
but looking at the front of that you is
the proposal to reuse effectively what's
already being used as a garage
exactly exactly Thank You councillor
cattle the picture that we saw out in
one of people parking further out I know
the footage no no what the fuzzy talks
is like what it's full the wah Aaron if
we could just keep pedaling back
somewhere where there are quite a lot of
cars parked the right-hand one there are
clearly a significant number of cars and
the I think that's a porch or something
else quite smart in the front it's
clearly parked on the pavement because
people are parking the pavement that is
actually an offense and preventing those
who might want to use the pavement
particularly those with a pushchair or
the elderly who may might not be able to
jump out of the way of a Porsche or
whatever else it may be and the question
is the question is is surely the
pavement is going to be at risk if you
start having garage doors opening here
on a regular basis to be able to allow
people in and out of your property is
there is that as a homeowner with a 12
week old baby in a two-year-old we don't
actually use the footpath because it's
not currently wide enough on that strip
to put a pushchair on it safely so when
we typically walk the dog
I typically walk along the left-hand
side of the road there to the corner
where we turn left and so I don't
necessarily see that it would endanger
users of of the footpath and given that
you would see them as you have to
quietly yep thank you very much thank
you
counselor fielding - then counselor
Barnes you go back to the plan which
that one yeah it shows in red I think
the full extent of the proposed
development is that correct
there so the red line boundary from that
extends over the footpath and on to
where the cars apart so the building be
brought forward at all no the building
is not going to change at all the
existing walls will remain so you're
within the system footprint it yep
existing footprint okay counselor parts
going back to my windows looking at the
pictures that we've seen since I spoke
can you estimate the distance between
right across the road or some at the
back mirror in all those trees sorry
which distance their distance from the
windows to across the road he looks to
me a substantial difference is it the
same that the back which point can we
their point of clarification okay thank
you
I've don't hear any more questions for
you thank you very much indeed thank you
thank you right can we get into points
of clarification out there yeah I've got
about cancer Harvey my goodness waiting
so patiently
you're five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman if it's worth the
wait
but the case officers pointed out this
proposed development is acceptable in
principle because I set out in policy as
10 countryside in villages it is to
quote a conversion to a residential use
of a building within the physical
confines of a village the proposed
development can therefore be regarded as
a rare windfall opportunity to make
better use of an existing building in a
way that's consistent with a s10 and the
principles of sustainable development
set out in that policy in the words of a
s10 the proposed development minimizes
the impact on the character of the local
landscape community and environmental
features it minimizes the impact on the
occupiers of existing properties in the
area it prioritizes the reuse an
existing building it avoids the loss of
any agricultural land and it's a
conversion that is appropriate to its
character and setting but there are two
substantial points of concern that the
case officers raised the first is the
matter of residential immunity and the
second I relate to the highways apart
it's true that the property was built as
a functional coach house not as a
residence the committee would have to
decide whether the fact that the setting
of the coach house is reliant upon the
space surrounding it happens to belong
to the adjacent properties rather than
to itself is of such material weight to
offset the other substantial merits of
the applications the case officer has
made something of the possibility of
overlooking most notably in relation to
roof lights it needs to be appreciated
that they're all already roof lights
installed in the rear of the property as
far as I'm aware they have not been the
subject of any concern previously only
the roof lights to the front or a new
feature and they are intended to provide
daylight into the living area for the
upper floor the lowest internal point of
the roof light is more than old money
five feet above the floor their purpose
is not to provide vantage points to
facilitate overlooking it's to allow
daylight into
residential space if the committee
shares these concerns however the matter
could be satisfactorily addressed by a
condition to use frosted glass to the
extent to which there is the possibility
of overlooking the street from the
windows in the downstairs bedroom this
could similarly be mitigated either by
the installation of frosted glass or the
normal use of curtains or indeed both
despite the applicant having
demonstrated there is intended to store
the normal three bins in inside the
garage the Highway Authority has
invented the speculation that they
should be stored outside the building
applications should not be influenced
let alone determined on the basis of
such as fifteen seconds sorry about that
can I carry on the issues of speeding
and parking are ubiquitous arms Scott is
no exception but the pressing issue that
has been addressed by the local action
group that's been has been the impact of
large lorries they blocked the road when
they meet in the hamlet and they shake
the foundations of building subjects
through the adjacent to the road and
that's why the Action Group has sought
and been successful in persuading the
County Council to install a seven and a
half ton weight restriction on the whole
of Ellington Road through an Scott true
there is a limited on street parking in
arm Scott but it's an intermittent issue
for significant portions of the week
there is a sufficient space the critical
driving force is the success of the
fuzzy dog it can sit 70 customers yet it
has a car park with a capacity for only
some 15 vehicles the overflow when it
occurs typically on Sunday lunch times
has its impact on the hamlet it doesn't
help the locals when the stat of the
fuzzy don't make a habit of parking on
the street rather than in their own car
park the addition of one car associated
with the proposed development can only
have a very marginal impact on the
overall parking position we norm Scott
the issues of the committee therefore is
to weigh the balance of the of the way
in which this application conforms to
the requirements
s10 and the extent to which the concerns
raised really carry weight I would argue
that the downsides to this application
are in practice either transient or
minimal a decision to approve will gain
the advantages of a rare windfall
opportunity and will preserve a
significant element of the historic
integrity of our Scott a decision to
refuse will deprive someone of a home
that meets their needs my request the
committee therefore is please don't let
the perfect be the enemy of the dog
Thank You mr. Valentine thank you very
much are there any questions for
councillor no questions you care about
that right points of clarification
councillor fielding question to our
learning solicitor highways if we grant
this against the comments from highways
what liability does the District Council
have well basically I mean most point
Commission's we don't know the duty of
care but when it comes to certain
matters if we go against certain
objections then we could have a duty of
care whether there's an accident etc
under highway there is case law to
suggest that if we go against the
Highway Authority objection than the
actual liability may transfer from the
highway authority to the District
Council so any future claim on only on
any accident will be made to the
district council unlikely and not likely
the highway authority so basically
councillors if we go in against a
highway objection then we need evidence
to basically confirm why they are
incorrect
councilor bones I was just going to ask
the distance between the windows in the
roof and the adjoining houses across the
road looks to me to be well above the
standard that is required which is I
think was 40 meters so I can confirm in
our SPD it's been adopted for a front to
front facing relationship we're looking
minimum separation distance of 30 meters
for one and a half or two storey
buildings and that would be in this case
the facing relationships for the ones
across the way front to front in this
case as proposed it would be substandard
towards than that by approximately two
meters and towards Williard corner which
is over here to the southwest of the
site by approximately half a meter so it
wouldn't meet the minimum separation
distances as proposed detail is set out
in page 54 of that detail is set out in
page 54 of the agenda
Celso kettle one of the comments coming
through in the correspondence is
concerned about overlooking and the
median value of that individual garden
but requests that in the event of the
window was open
that's how words or wine or and frosted
that that individual would be
comfortable with the application has
that request from the commentator for
the respondent being reflected in the
applications we stand or is it can it be
conditioned so that has been considered
consider we did receive to third-party
comments in response to this application
one did suggest if the windows on the
rear obscure glazed and limited open
there's a window here as well served in
the garage at the lower level that they
wouldn't have any concerns what we have
to look at is the development as a whole
we can obscure glaze conditioned windows
in certain circumstances and limit the
opening make sure they open in Whitley
in this case where the building is the
red line only and not any land beyond
but we have to look at the impact on the
future occupiers of the new dword
dwelling which is a single bedroom
dwelling and in this case officers were
concerned that to achieve an acceptable
level of amenity for neighboring
properties would result an unacceptable
impact on the future occupiers of the
building that's proposed that's why we
haven't sought to overcome the concerns
of our planning condition in this case I
think what I would just add is that if
you're looking at proposal sometime and
you perhaps want a compromise position
and you want to compromise by obscure
glazing one window perhaps that's okay
obscuring tulip windows mm obscuring
windows on an entire elevation our
multiple elevations what you are looking
at is a scheme that is poorly designed
and causes harm probably to the future
occupiers of that dwelling Council
building further question to our Leonard
severe it's a solicitor if they are
they're referring to
doors opening onto the footpath and
therefore the bridges highways but
they've already got right to do it and
are using them anyway to bring them cars
into the sole garage that they have at
the moment surely there are permitted
development rights for that usage can I
just clarify I'm not learning anyway
any barristers are learning lots
Lister's I'm afraid becoming a
frightening might not learn and I'm
afraid I think the issue here and Aaron
will back me up on this I think it's the
intensification I'm in bass yes the
doors coming out onto the highway would
be an obstruction anyway and that is a
criminal offense but I think the issue
is intensification of the actual
development and that's where the
counting you have got issues yes just
about that's correct and in their
comments the Highways Authority do
recognise the existing relationship with
the outbuilding and the gaya doors
opening outwards in their view the use
of the separate dwelling house would be
an intensification of the use and that's
where the concerns are stemming from
changed the doors to roll up or other
means of dealing with it that would
affect the frontage of the building
would that that is in the application
that's before members today so I don't
think we could give that a great deal of
weight in our considerations what I
would add in addition to what Aaron was
discussing is that the intensification
will mean this cars coming and going
more often from this building we talked
a little bit and we've heard a little
bit about the fact that this garage
element would be substandard in terms of
size our SPD gives us guidance in
respect of what is an appropriate size
for a garage so that it can be used not
just successfully for housing a car but
also for all the storage needs this
clearly falls short of that standard and
therefore it is very reasonable of the
highway officer to suggest that there
may be a requirement for elements of
storage whether that be refuse bikes
whatever it is to occur within the
highway so there's the combination of
those factors the fact that they will be
opening over the highway of these gates
that were coming and going from the
garage the garage is not other size
that's fully adequate
leads them to put forward quite clear
objection I just know today which is
that the only expert evidence we've got
so far is from the County Council yes we
can rebut what they say but we need some
evidence to actually but it and it
basically if we're not gonna provide
that evidence then like I said the
liability if we approve this application
may pass from the county of Highway
Authority to the District Council
Catholic Hetal if we were to defer we
haven't got to debate yet so we can't
make this proposal but if we were to
defer could we request further details
of how I mean highways objection is
quite clear the original consultation
raised issues these those issues have
not been addressed and therefore the
highways clearly do have been consistent
in their view and I'm slightly alarmed
by your suggestion that we would be
liable but I can understand where that's
coming from even if you're not learning
I take that point
could we get around that by deferring
and asking the resident or the applicant
sorry to come back and clarify on
particular highways issue because I
think this is pretty fundamental this is
the main reason for objection and I
think historically we've always looked
at highways objections with an awful lot
of seriousness and therefore whilst I
completely take counts the harvey's
argument that this is a good use of a
redundant space if we go against
highways we are effectively hitting on a
head against a potential brick wall as
it were could we go down that route and
ask them to try and relook at this and
provide information of substant
committee which might throw a more
favorable light and enable highway to be
a little bit more comfortable
under the same opinion mr. chairman yeah
just for a moment hang up we could have
a German just for deployment maybe the
way forward in the respect implicated in
the properly tell Peter we got a chance
for a couple minutes
Thank You counselor kettle in response
to the question over whether this would
be a reasonable thing to defer I think
it's personal and to say that this
application has been with us for some
time the highway offices comments have
have been received for for some time and
the plan before members tonight is in
fact an amendment scheme which is the
applicants endeavor to respond to the
concerns of the highway authority
initially there was further storage
within the garage area area which would
limited its space for a car and that has
been changed those changes have not
overcome the concerns of the highway
authority and officers and local
planning authorities are charged with
determining applications expeditiously I
think it's reasonable of the applicant
to want a decision on the plan before us
tonight I don't think I would see the
purpose of deferring this application
when the highway authorities objections
are multiple and multifaceted it is not
just simply down to the type of door
that's on it goes beyond that can I come
can I just follow up them I'm not I'm
not in any way saying that it is purely
about the shape or the style or how the
door lifts up or sideways or whatever
else it may do there are as you quite
rightly say a number of issues highways
have raised which they're not
comfortable with could we know we are
here to support good applications and
I've cast for Harveys made some very
valid points about the accommodation
side but that we've got this a collision
between the two props probably the wrong
word to use could would it be possible
for us to ask that the app can go way
out look at this and see whether there
is a amendment that would look at a
number
she's right into highways rather than be
put in position where we have to decide
to take on the liability or not as mr.
Nash's pointed out I mean just to expand
on what David saying the the basis under
the applicant has had plenty of time to
sort this matter out basically I and I
don't like to do this but I'm kind of
like taking the decision out of your
hands there this is a legal point the
county rejected so basically you need to
rebut it but you need to rebut it by
evidence and at the moment there's no
other evidence than the County Council's
counselor fielding yes it's not listed
and it's not in a conservation area now
we're considering the proposal that's
before us I know and we have receive
revised plans during the course of the
application in response to the highways
objection and the concerns raised by
officers in terms of the overlooking
relationships and the amenity concerns
and that's where we've received the
revised plan that removed the storage
and a statement saying that they've got
the existing garage doors open out onto
the foot way we consulted with the
Highways Authority and they responded on
the 17th of September in response to
these revised plans and referred back to
their earlier objection of the view that
they haven't addressed the concerns that
have been raised counselor kettle
mr. Nash has made it very clear we have
evidence and highways of authority we
have no other evidence therefore I think
that in a way I would say argues towards
the position I'm putting forward and
asking them to put evidence because we
haven't gotten a and say if you want
this to go through we have to have
evidence and therefore if we were or we
get the debate put forward a deferral
then it is the the onus is on them if
they cannot provide any evidence this
committee has done everything they can
to help them get this application
through but they've got to do it just
one question if this application was
first down
the lone flat with an it isn't and I
exert Aaron's got to say we've got to
look at the application in front of us
and quite right that we've had the
discussion many times in ships to which
where there is no parking for the absol
t and people are supposed to use public
parking could this application if
parking was not allowed in the gallery
for the reasons highways it's a concern
would that be something oh would you be
able to park on the street would have
been application we'd have to consider
each application on its own merit in
this case we're in an all of the
settlement we're not in a main rural
center or stratford-upon-avon town and
so in terms of other transport options
and they are more limited compared to
other locations and our SPD requires one
parking space for a one-bedroom unit
which is what's been proposed at the
moment it's our concern about how
practical that is returning on your
comment councillor capital in terms of
deferral as I say the the application
has been with us for a large amount of
time and they've known about these
concerns they've tried to respond
they've known it's coming to committee
it has always been in the applicants
gift to withdraw this application and
reconsider what evidence they might want
to submit for resubmission and to
support it and allow us to then re
consult with the highway authority they
have chosen not to do that what they
want is a decision out of the committee
I think it's not unreasonable for this
committee to provide them that decision
something very simple misses the bins
are they allow you to be stored in the
garage it's a condition so at the moment
it's just a building the red line shows
up to the foot way because of the access
so the doors open across the access
that's why they sell areas proposed
there's no outdoor amenity space
proposed with the development so the bin
storage is shown inside the garage area
but just here so on that guy is it is
there no other door in - there must be
another door into the garret
that's the only access is from just from
the garage door
yeah it's externally accessed and not
internally access really the other side
sorry I Cal so fielding I'm so sorry
councillor Barnes we certainly stealing
well I think we're educated musician in
the respect that
whether excite indoors or going up and
down doors or whatever we refuse the
application I'm sure that wants the
problems that we've got addressed by the
highway go through can we now go to the
debates then please Jennings issues
wouldn't hold much weight to and would
be all for it
but I think the problem is is this
highway is the highways matter and I
don't think anyone here can argue on a
legal basis against the county and I say
this is just a real shame that there
isn't another option for and I don't
know again going to judge each one each
of these planning applications on what's
before you I don't know whether the
owner owns the whole plot owns the house
behind it could put the car park in the
back and we'd probably go yeah we were
all for it
but on what's here in front of us with
the highways issue it's a real problem -
I really want to say I won't really want
to grant it but it's the highways issues
stopping me
let me so I just want point on cancel
Jenny's you cannot argue the county of
not always right but you need evidence
to rebut it that's touch the points and
we haven't gotten nothing counselor
careful I think I'm very much work my
colleague is this is a good use I'm not
convinced about the immunity argument
that there isn't a garden there isn't
this there isn't that if you lived in a
city of 20 stories up in fact you
wouldn't have a garden either and you've
got far more green space around this
particular property around arm scope
that you would have in a block of flats
so I don't think that is a reason why we
should refuse it it is a good reuse on
the building I'm disappointed
mr Fielding a jumped in with the refusal
before listening to a debate John
because I would have liked to give the
applicant the opportunity by deferring
to say come back I can't do that because
mr. fielding put before the proposal
unless he wants to withdraw it and allow
us to put it a federal place which will
allow them with the full force this
gritty to turn around say think again
work out a way of doing it as Aaron has
quite rightly said that came from
highways in or think about me David on
the whatever it was a September
some time ago but if you want this to go
through applicant give us the evidence
to help you so if John is preferred of a
draw that I would put prepared but at a
feral foot forward but that's up
payments in within his room it counts
appealing in my view we've asked a
number of questions with regards this it
is the highways problem the highways of
or rather our liability as a District
Council if they want to come back then
it's entirely up to them
application but I can't see after what
David Jeffries has said that think we
can really give them any more time on
this scheme because it's already been
before them for a number of months so I
think it's got to get sorted out with
them and highways thanks cam Seidel the
roving have you proposed that is my
proposal to support the officers
recommendation do I have a second for
that do you have a second for that Thank
You councillor Mills just taking the
temperature of the room and I know
councillor feeling has moved a proposal
in accordance with the officers
recommendation I've heard a number of
counselors discuss the matter and not
find themselves in support of the
amenity reason for refusal I'd just like
to clarify the counts on the fielding if
possible whether his proposal is to
refuse the application in line with the
officers recommendation including the
reason for refuse or relating to impact
it on immunity my reason is in line with
what you're saying but particularly with
regards to highways right do we have a
seconder for councillor Fleming vote on
that the officers recommendation to
review to refused to refuse the
application
against one channel abstentions
Jerusalem becomes resolved to refuse the
council resolves to refuse the
application thank you ladies and
gentlemen have you had any urgent
business
no thank you meeting ending acts 8:35